four years ago I was attacked by Beyonce
fans and this is that story before I
start this I want to say something that
I don't think should matter in context
of this story but it matters to me I
have been a Beyonce fan since Destiny's
trial that's before a lot of you were
even born I love Beyonce but I wouldn't
kill for her anyways so this all
happened four years ago at the time I
was the animals editor for BuzzFeed
basically what that means is that I was
in charge of all the animals content for
this site and I would also write posts
but he pretty much lets you write
whatever you want which is really
awesome so one day I was finishing up my
posts and I came across this article
that said a panda had faked her own
pregnancy so she could get extra treats
and be in air-conditioning I mean how
amazing is that she saw that other
pandas who were pregnant got to have
special treatment that's like the best
long con I've ever heard of honestly we
should just do an entire video on this
anyways I clearly loved the story and I
had already hit my quota for the day so
I decided to write something a little
bit so the post that I decided to do
about it was writing in the voice of a
panda saying that it was a feminist
stance that she was taking because she
should be treated well and her worth
shouldn't be based on if she procreate
or not I don't even think that many
people were gonna see this
I finished the post I hit publish and I
went on with my day later that night I
started getting tons of Twitter
notifications [ __ ] don't [ __ ] hate
on the Queen [ __ ]
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] my twitter handle
equals trash okay so this one might be
my favorite you look like one of them
cheap 65c Barbies at Walmart I hope you
catch Ebola you vanilla chipmunk built
in the face [ __ ] [ __ ] what does KY ask
me kill yourself oh that's nice I had
never been attacked by that many people
online all at once and was just
genuinely compete
and then he started to notice that a lot
of the accounts had something in common
they either were Beyonce fan accounts or
were hashtagging agency which only made
me more confused I love Beyonce and I've
never really written about her online I
read about animals did they mistake me
for someone else
did they mistake me for someone who
would openly [ __ ] on a celebrity did
they mistake me for someone that doesn't
like Beyonce I did something that you're
never supposed to do I fed the trolls it
wasn't much I just replied to one of the
tweets with a simple question mark and
all I got back was but I did not know
what I did finally a friendlier member
of the Bajan C tweeted my article about
the Panda Abbi
oh so you happen to use Beyonce for this
article and then I remembered I had used
a picture of Beyonce in my article about
the Panda she had just done her amazing
MTV performance where she stood in front
of a sign that said feminist it was
nothing short of iconic so naturally
when I was looking for a visual to
describe feminism I thought of that so I
slapped a panda head on Beyonce's body
and I called it a day but realizing this
did not help me figure out what the
problem was luckily another nice fan
account tweeted at me oh you don't
remember the rumors about Beyonce faking
her own pregnancy two years ago I was
being dragged for a two-year old rumor
about Beyonce a rumor I had completely
forgotten about because one I don't
think she did faked her pregnancy to if
she did none of my business
three there's nothing wrong with getting
a surrogate or why would I use a post
about a panda to really stick it to
Beyonce two years later so I'm in the
thick of it and I'm trying to explain
that I'm actually a Beyonce fan but they
just kept piling on one person called me
adorable another called me a pumpkin
head and one person said Beyonce would
end
guys I don't think Beyonce cares enough
about me to end me but I appreciate that
you think she does so this kind of
trolling and mean comments and death
threats went on till morning so I get to
work and I realize I think I found my
way out I have a man on the inside so at
the time I was sitting next to internet
celebrity but more importantly notable
Beyonce fan Matt bell si
so Matt was gracious enough to pull me
out of the rubble and tweet at one of
the main fan accounts that I was indeed
a Beyonce fan like magic it stopped the
hive had stopped their swarm for a day
just a side note that's some real power
right there
and with great power comes great
responsibility can you cut that out so
the thing that stuck with me about all
of this was that there were so many
people willing to tell a stranger to die
or kill themself over what was
ultimately a misunderstanding so I
looked at some of the people's profiles
because I was curious like what else
they tweeted about the rest of their
timeline was just tweeting about how
they were having a normal nice evening
with their boyfriend
I listened I was at the time 26 been
working on the internet for a while and
I have a relatively thick skin about
this stuff but what if I wasn't what if
I was 12 or having an exceptionally bad
day I might not be telling this story as
a funny story when you're tweeting at me
like I'm a person overall I just feel
like everyone needs to chill maybe put
on some Beyonce
[Music]